can either build the talent train
someone Etc or you can buy the talent we
just went to try and interview as many
vendors as we could for each platform I
thought of it as like how can we get a
killer on every platform all they're
thinking about is how to grow this one
thing the whole Playbook is go find
somebody who's really good interview
lots of them if you don't learn from
them on the interview don't hire them
because then they don't know more than
you do it honestly becomes pretty clear
if you talk to like 10 LinkedIn vendors
who actually knows what they're talking
about so once we get the person we make
it clear to them that we're only going
to be doing this for three to six months
with you because our goal is to
absolutely copy everything you're doing
and bring it in-house since we're very
upfront about that everyone's been cool
with that you get all the learning that
they've already learned across other
companies for me that's shortcut a lot
of the figuring it out